おはようございます。
今日のプリティーシリーズニュースをお届けします。
まずはおねがいアイプリです。
昨日からおねがいアイプリ 2だんが本格スタートしました。
ゲーム公式Xでは、ハッピーバースデー！
コーデの登場が案内されており、毎月最初のプレイで入手できる特別コーデ企画が始まっています。
新アイプリおりびあや新デュオコーデ関連のプレイ報告もSNS上で急増しており、プレイヤーの間で新弾の研究やカード交換が活発になっています。
また、リズダムとのスペシャルコラボもスタートしました。
コラボ限定アイプリカードやクリアファイルがもらえるキャンペーンが開始され、ファンの間では入手報告やプレイ動画の投稿が目立っています。
続いてプリパラ関連です。
アイドルランドプリパラでは、前日にスタートしたファララ・ガァララ誕生日企画の盛り上がりが継続中です。
SNSでは誕生日記念フォトやお祝いイラストの投稿が多数見られ、ファンコミュニティ全体でお祝いムードが続いています。
公式配信中の不思議の国のノンシュガー関連コンテンツについてもプレイ報告が増えています。
続いてキングオブプリズムです。
公式Xでは、Prism White Bear Cafeコラボグッズ販売開始の告知が引き続き話題となっています。
販売開始直後から購入報告やグッズ写真が多数投稿されており、特に10周年関連ビジュアルを使用したアイテムへの注目度が高まっています。
さらに、6月28日開催のキングオブプリズム Pretty Boys SPECIAL サンクス PARTY！
およびキングオブプリズム SUPER LIVE Prism☆Tours！
について、来場案内や公演情報の周知が行われています。
昼公演は上映イベント、夜公演はライブイベントという異なる構成で実施されることが改めて案内され、参加予定者による話題が広がっています。
今日のプリティーシリーズ界隈は、おねがいアイプリ 2だん稼働開始後の盛り上がりと、リズダムコラボ開始、そしてキングオブプリズム10周年関連企画への注目が中心となりました。
それでは、今日も素敵なプリティーシリーズライフをお過ごしください。
以上、今日のアイプリニュースでした。